What we have here
is a degree
which I've been authorized to present
University of Berkshire Hathaway
bestows an honorary PhD to this
phenomenally hard-working deal maker
Ron Allen in this case
in appreciation for your insights and
advice in the Clayton Homes acquisition
awarded on this day October 14th by the
Dean over here.
And on the other side it has a share of
B stock that will
go to Ron Allen as part of this
graduation ceremony.
Ron, you're the first awardee here of
Thank you very much.
Okay, this side is more valuable than
that. I'm not sure.
Okay.
Major funding for this program was
provided by the Clayton Family
Foundation.
And by Clayton Homes, building
affordable homes for families and
individuals throughout the United
States.
The University of Tennessee College of
Business Administration is proud of its
association with Warren Buffett.
Since 1999 our finance students have
made an annual trip to Omaha, Nebraska
led by Professor Al Auxier
to meet with and learn from the Oracle
of Omaha, Warren Buffett.
During their February 2003 visit the
students presented Mr. Buffett with a
gift that triggered the events leading
to Berkshire Hathaway's purchase of
Knoxville-based Clayton Homes, a leader
in the manufactured housing industry.
But Mr. Buffett tells the story best.
It was really rather remarkable. I'm not
sure there's ever been any
acquisition in history that had
had quite this
background.
You know, the students came up in the in
the earlier years
and they would bring a football
or a basketball
and then this particular crop from last
year or early this year
came and they did bring the book about
Jim Clayton
and by Jim Clayton and
that turned into
a $1.7 billion deal.
To show his appreciation to those
University of Tennessee students and
faculty Mr. Buffett honored the college
in the fall of 2003
with an on-campus visit to speak with
both MBA and finance students at the
college's annual MBA symposium.
While on campus, he surprised those who
visited him in February with a generous
gift of stock in Berkshire Hathaway.
Warren Buffett, who is recognized as the
second wealthiest individual in the
world is respected and admired in part
because of his common sense and
straightforward approach to investing
which you will better understand and
appreciate after watching this video.
Please join us in watching and learning
from Warren Buffett as he answers
students' questions and shares with our
students and faculty his investment
philosophy and wealth of experience.
Mr. Buffett, what were your biggest
investment mistakes and what lessons did
you learn from those that you can share
with us?
Yeah. The biggest investment mistakes
have been
mistakes of
omission rather than commission. I mean,
you see
you see in our balance in our income
statement the mistakes that result from
commission.
But accounting doesn't pick up
the mistakes of omission and they're the
huge ones.
And nobody knows about it unless
I feel in the mood to confess, which I
don't often, but since you asked
I would say
the biggest mistake I've named a couple
in the past.
I used to always name the Fannie Mae
stock we didn't purchase in the early
'80s. Now, I don't count as a mistake
not buying Microsoft, for example. I met
Bill Gates
on July 5th, 1991.
He spent about 10 hours explaining
Microsoft to me.
He did it with an orangutan the next
day. He said that was easier. But
but I and I it was fascinating to me.
And I you know, I knew he was a terrific
guy and a terrific manager and that
Microsoft was a terrific company. So, I
went back and bought 100 shares just to
keep track of it, but I I didn't know
enough to make the decision. I really
didn't know what other people were doing
in the field and and so it was outside
of what I call my circle of competence.
And important thing in investing is not
how big your circle is, it's knowing
where the perimeter is so that you stay
within
the circle. And we try to do that. Now,
Fannie Mae was in my circle of
competence in the early 1980s. So
when I miss something like that, I
deserve a thumb-sucking award,
basically.
If I miss, you know, all kinds of other
things
that doesn't really make any difference,
but I missed that one. That cost
billions of dollars. Never shows up in
our financial statements.
The example I use
more often now
is more recent was I set out, this is
even worse
I set out to buy 100 million shares
pre-split, 200 million shares of the
present stock
of Walmart about five or six years ago.
It was at $23 a share.
So, it would have cost us 2 billion
three if we'd bought it.
If we had bought it, it would be worth
about 11 and 1/2 or 12 billion
now. I knew enough to understand
Walmart. I mean, I knew it was a you
know, the retailing machine of all time.
Uh
and what happened on that was I bought
a few million shares
and then it it went up. It probably went
up to 23 and 1/8. Now, when a stock goes
from 23 to 23 and 1/8, I mean, that's a
major event around Berkshire. I have I
have trouble adjusting. I mean, my
license plate says thrifty.
And the guy who designed it knew what he
was saying. And so, like a dope
I I I just said, "Well, I'll wait until
it gets
back to where I was buying." It was a
little more than an eighth, but
nevertheless I just And and of course
it's
I missed out on 8 or 9 billion, you
know. So, that's that's a mistake
of Now I Now that you're a B
shareholder, I mean, don't don't raise
hell about this at the meeting, but
uh
the uh
But those are the mistakes you don't
see.
Uh
Mistakes that you can see
is Berkshire Hathaway literally
today
is a merger of three companies in my
business lifetime. There was the
original Berkshire Hathaway which we
bought into
in 1965 or bought control of in early
1965. And then there were two other
company called Blue Chip Stamps, a
trading stamp company in California, and
Diversified Retailing, a company that
started out with a department store in
Baltimore.
The Diversified and Blue Chip got merged
into Berkshire. So, that's that's where
it all comes from.
All three of those were mistakes. I
mean, the
starting with the textile business,
Berkshire was a textile company with 20
million of net worth. The whole 20
million was tied up in the textile
business and it was a lousy business.
I bought it because it was cheap, not
because it was good.
And that's a mistake
took me a long time to get over that. I
I I I learned under a fellow
who was a magnificent human being,
magnificent teacher
and did all kinds of things for me.
Uh he put the emphasis on buying things
that were quantitatively cheap.
Uh that was the background from the '30s
and '40s. I call it the used cigar butt
approach to investing. I mean, you you
go around, you walk down the street and
you see a cigar butt and it's kind of
soggy and disgusting and
repels you, but it's free. And there
And there may And there may be one puff
left in it.
So, you think, "What can I lose?" You
know, I mean. So, you pick it up and you
see and then maybe there's one puff in
it, but it didn't cost you anything. So,
all that is all you've had is a soggy
cigar butt in your mouth. And that that
was Berkshire Hathaway back in 1965. It
was the wrong kind of business to buy.
It had actually lost significant money
over the previous 10 years, but it was
very cheap.
So, I bought in and then all of a sudden
I owned a textile business.
A New England textile business.
A
New England textile business in New
Bedford, Mass where about 100 textile
companies had gone out of business and
we were the last ones really foolish
enough to be trying to make a profit.
So, it was a terrible base
to build
what has become Berkshire Hathaway on. I
mean, we we sat with that 20 million,
which was originally 100% of our
capital, we sat with that for about 20
years trying to make it work and it
never worked. So, if I'd done the things
subsequently did in insurance and See's
Candy and all kinds of other businesses
and done it from scratch and not put
them in Berkshire
you know, maybe Gates would have to move
over.
The
uh
Diversified Retailing, we went into
Baltimore
bought a department store in 1966. We
thought we were buying a second-class
department store at a third-class price.
We were buying a fourth-class department
store at a third-class price
and that sunk in after a few years, but
that was a mistake.
Blue Chip Stamps
was a trading stamp company and most of
you are too young to remember, but in
the '60s particularly there was this
huge rage and S&H was a huge company and
Blue Chip was set up in California and
literally it did 120 million of business
in 1967
or eight when we bought it.
And now it does about $50,000 a year.
So, it's under our careful management
you know, lots of effort. We've taken it
from 120 million in sales down to about
50,000 and we'll get the rest of the way
before long.
Uh
You know, it was that we we bought into
a hula hoop and we didn't know it at the
time. So, with that great background,
those all three were mistakes.
Now
put them all together
three mistakes put together, you know,
one each becomes three mistakes in one
pile. But we did go into to other
businesses. I learned after a point that
the real thing in
in business is to be in good businesses
with good people. And that's what works.
And it's much more important than trying
to buy something cheap, which doesn't It
may work okay occasionally, but it's no
way to build a a business over time. So,
those three were mistakes
of commission.
Even more, the Walmarts and the Fannie
Maes are omission.
And we'll have new ones next year. You
know, I I will have a section in the
report this year called the dumbest
thing I did this year. It may take half
the report, you know. I mean, who knows?
Uh but it's
I don't look I I I don't dwell on them
in the least. It doesn't make any
difference. I mean, I've I've been
having fun the whole time and I'll
continue to have fun. And actually, you
know, if you played golf and you scored
a hole-in-one on every hole, it wouldn't
be an interesting game after a while. I
mean, if had some magnet in the hole
someplace and the ball automatically
went to it, you'd give up golf. That's
It's much more fun to
to play the game, par threes, par fives,
occasionally hit one in the rough, and
so on. It's it It's a lot of fun. So, I
That's as much as I wish to confess to
today.
My name's August Heineman. Good to see
you. Uh Mr. Buffett, could you suggest
some books or other resources that might
prove beneficial for investment
decisions that we make? Yeah.
The
by far the best book on investing,
and it shaped my total investing
framework, uh was one I read when I was
19. And it was It's called The
Intelligent Investor. It came out when I
was
at the University of Nebraska uh
in 1949.
Uh I had started investing when I was
11.
I I just
dithered away until uh you know, seven
when I was seven and eight and nine. But
so, unfortunately, I didn't get started
until I was 11. But I bought my first
stock when I was 11, and then I
experimented with a whole bunch of
things, the timing of stocks and
charting and doing all these crazy
things. It was a lot of fun.
Profitless, but a lot of fun. And I did
that until I was 19.
And I read all the books on investing in
the public library.
I I I I ate it up. And I it was a lot
you know, it it was fascinating to me,
but I had no framework. I was just
searching for something. I was hoping
that little things on a chart would tell
me something about what a stock was
going to do. I mean, it was kind of
crazy, but everybody else was doing it,
so I figured I'd do it, too. Uh
sometimes I should turn the chart upside
down, you know. It still wouldn't help.
Uh
And then in then in in 1949, I read the
Intelligent Investor by Ben Graham.
I'd never heard of him up till then. And
there are really only two chapters in
that book that are the key to it. But
they set my philosophical framework for
investing
in three ways.
Uh they're so basic and so simple
that they're you know, they're hard to
It's hard to understand how they could
be that important. But the Ten
Commandments are simple, you know. It
The
The first is
that a stock is part of a business. I
mean, you you can't think of a stock as
something different. It's You value a
business, and then you divide by the
shares outstanding. But what you have to
think about is what kind of a business
are you getting into, what are its
economic characteristics, who are its
competitors, what's its management like,
all of these things that relate to a
business instead of a little ticker
symbol. I used to know when I was 11 or
12 the ticker symbols of every company
virtually on the New York Stock
Exchange. I could mark the boards at
Harris, Upham, you know. But I didn't
know anything. I mean, I could you know,
I knew that X was U.S. Steel and T was
AT&T, and so on. But I didn't I didn't
know anything. I didn't know what was
behind them. So, I had to start looking
at at these
little symbols or these little names in
the paper as businesses and decide, "How
do you value a business? What counts?"
The second thing in that in in the book
is that Graham gives you a marvelous
set point in terms of how the investor
should react to stock market
fluctuations. He talks about his
mythical Mr. Market in chapter eight.
And there's been no better thing written
in terms of the investor's attitude
toward stock prices. Most people
react the wrong way to stock prices. I
mean, they feel good when their stocks
go up, they feel bad when they go down.
They think the stock market is there to
instruct them.
And Mr. Market is this partner you have
in investing.
You know, he's a remarkably obliging
partner. This guy comes around every day
and he tells you what he'll pay you for
your interest in the business, or what
he'll sell you more
at the same price. Nobody ever does that
in in in private business. If you owned
If you and I owned a gas station
together,
and I said every day I want you to come
in and offer me your half interest in
the station, and I can either buy your
half or sell you my my half at the same
price,
and you have to come in every day and do
it, you'd be at a terrible disadvantage.
And you'd be at a particular
disadvantage if you're Mr. Market in the
market, because Mr. Market,
our our friend of the market who
obligingly gives you those figures every
day, different figures at the end of the
day and the start of the day, but he's
naming a price at which he'll either buy
or sell.
The beautiful thing about him
is that this guy is an alcoholic manic
depressive. I mean,
I mean, he is as unsound as they come.
He wanders around all day, you know,
and looks at the crazy things, and he
you know, he he's going to name all
kinds of crazy prices.
And you don't have to pay any attention
to him
except when it's to your advantage to do
so. If that's once a year, if it's once
every five years, it's one stock out of
3,000,
all you have to do is sit there. You
have no moral responsibility to this
jerk, you know. I mean, he's he is
naming these numbers. You didn't ask him
to, but he's doing it. And all you have
to do is pick the one time
when he is particularly depressed or
particularly manic or particularly drunk
or whatever it may be. And the market
will be all of those things. And
and you take advantage of it. And And
that's what's remarkable about stocks,
if you think about it,
is that if you look at the high and low
on all of these American companies for
the last year, you'll see case after
case after case where the high is twice
below.
Now, that's for a sound American
business that's running along, paying
people, selling goods, and so on. If you
go out and look at farmland
10 miles from here,
there's no way in the world over a year
that the farmland is going to range in
value from X to 2X. It doesn't It maybe
go from X to 110% of X or vice versa. If
you look at an apartment house near
here, and get figures on essentially
apartment houses like that over a year,
it won't it won't move 10% in a given
year. But here are the finest of
American businesses, and people just
name these numbers that go all over the
place.
And you don't have to play except when
you want to. That's the important thing.
And that's the That's what Graham tells
you. The market isn't there to instruct
you,
to tell you anything.
The market is there just basically to
serve you when you want it to serve you.
You know, one of the most important
things to remember in stocks, very hard
to do, but people have all these
feelings about it. The stock doesn't
know you own it.
You know, you're sitting there with
these certificates for Berkshire. The
company doesn't even know you own it,
you know. The stock doesn't. It's
trading now, and they don't know you own
it. So, it has no feelings about you. I
mean, you've got all these feelings
about it, but it's just part of a
business.
If Berkshire is worth 75,000 times a
million and a half shares,
you know, roughly 110 billion or
something like that,
it's a good investment. If it isn't,
it's a lousy investment, you know. And
you have to value the business. And
Graham,
you know, it's amazing, but people don't
do that in Wall Street.
You You bet you you hear price targets
or that kind of thing. But you'd see no
one write a paper that says, "Here's the
nature of this business over the next 20
years,
you know, what will that What should
that business sell for?" Forget about
what it's selling for. In fact, one of
the things I always like to do when I'm
looking at investments, is I like to
look at them without knowing the price.
Uh because if you see the price, it
automatically has some influence on you.
If you just sit down with the reports,
I I If somebody If I get an idea about
looking up a company, and I get the
10-Ks and so on, I would rather not know
the price, cuz I'd rather value it
without knowing the price. When I used
to handicap horses when I was a kid, one
of the things I would do is I'd get the
racing form ahead of time.
And if there were nine horses in a race,
we'll say,
obviously, the probabilities of
of each one winning the race had to add
up to 100%.
I mean, one horse was going to win the
race absent a dead heat or all of them
dropping dead on the backstretch. So,
if you went through the racing form, and
I would look at the third race at
Hialeah,
I would try to figure out the percentage
chance of each horse winning the race,
and that had to add to 100%. Then I
would compare those percentages to the
odds. But I First of all, I wouldn't
look at the odds first. I would look at
the past performance and all of that
thing first. Stock market's the same
way.
Third thing in Graham's book is the
margin of safety.
You don't
If you come up to a bridge and it says,
"Capacity 10,000 lb,"
and you're driving a 9,800-lb truck, you
drive down further and find another
bridge. I mean, you know, they Nobody
knows exactly what what that capacity
is, and it may have been sign may have
been put up three years ago. So, you
always leave a margin of safety. You
don't you don't try
to cut things that close. You wait till
something kind of shouts at you in the
stock market. And uh
with those three principles, you can
build all kinds of build a all kinds of
structures on that. But that's the
foundation. And if you've got that in
mind, and that's in the Intelligent
Investor. I've never found anything that
remotely compares with it.
You touched on this a little bit
already, Mr. Buffett, but as a follower
of Ben Graham,
what one piece of Graham's advice would
you say has had the most impact on you?
Well,
all three of the ones I just
named in a sense have had I mean, they
they You You can't get rid of one leg of
the three-legged stool and and still
have a a good investment philosophy. But
uh I would say that
uh the most important thing
uh over a long period and working with
big money,
uh is to understand the business. I
mean,
uh if let's just say for the moment
that you were
given a million dollars
or whatever sum was necessary, and you
could
uh
look around Knoxville
or look around all of Tennessee if you
want
and buy into any three businesses
you know, between now and a week from
now.
Private businesses.
So, they
they're not trading or anything of the
sort.
And you've got a week to do it or you
have to give the money back.
Now, what will be you be doing in during
the next week? I mean, you can look at
all these companies, some of them you're
quite familiar with, some of them you're
less familiar with, some of them you
know by reputation, some of them you
know the management, some of them you
don't
you know, you know their competitive
situation, you know.
What will you be thinking about
during that 7-day period? How will you
actually be screening these companies
out?
I think you'll look
for three businesses
and you can't trade them after you buy
them, you're just going to you're going
to own them the rest of your life.
You're going to be looking for three
businesses, you're going to be looking
for businesses
that have enduring competitive
advantage.
You know, you you don't want
to buy a
Burger King franchise just because
nobody's come within 10 miles of it yet
because you know Wendy's and Donald's
and all of those will be there pretty
soon. I mean,
you you know, it isn't necessarily who's
earning the most money now. It you you
you're going to look for something with
enduring competitive advantage.
Now, that takes a business
with some kind of a moat around it
because capitalism
by definition
is is is is a system where every time
somebody has an economic castle
somebody else is going to come after. I
mean, it's just the nature. If you open
a restaurant and it's successful here in
town, you know, somebody's going to take
your menu and probably take your chef
maybe cut your price, maybe offer a
little more parking, maybe be a better
better okay, whatever. I mean,
capitalism consists of going after the
other guy's castle.
Now,
if that's the case, you want a castle
with a big moat around it.
And there's a lot of ways you can have a
moat around something. You could have it
by patent protection.
You could have it by location in certain
certain areas. I mean,
if you own if you have something in
people's mind like Coca-Cola, 6 billion
people in the world, practically all of
them have something in their mind about
Coca-Cola, largely favorable.
They don't have anything in their mind
about RC Cola, you know.
And if RC Cola spent a billion dollars
advertising, they wouldn't have anything
in their mind about RC Cola. But they've
got something in their mind about Coke
and generally it's favorable. That's why
Coke wants to be where people are happy
because they want to be at the theater,
they want to be at Disney World, they
want to be at the World Series. They
want they want always have you drinking
that
that drink of Coca-Cola while at the
same time experiencing happiness. And if
they do that
they're going to sell a lot of
Coca-Cola. And it won't make any
difference if somebody is a half a cent
less on some serving than Coke. So,
that's an enduring competitive
advantage.
And you want it run by honest and able
people.
You don't want to go in with a crook and
you don't want to go in with a dope.
Now, the best businesses to buy are the
ones where you could have a dope in
there. I mean, Peter Lynch says, you
know, buy a business
that's so good that an idiot can run it
because sooner or later one will, you
know, and and
there's some merit to that, you know, at
the
uh in fact, I got a question the other
day
that from a student group and they said,
you know, what's going to happen to
Berkshire when you go gaga?
And I said, well, Berkshire is so good
that I can go gaga. In fact, I may even
be, you know,
those are the kind of businesses to own.
So, you want it but you want a
management that's able and honest. And
then you want a price that's sensible.
And that's what you'd look for. You'd go
around Tennessee
got a week to do it and you'd
immediately screen out a whole bunch of
things. You just know that they weren't
a fertile area, you know.
And the
that's an important thing to be able to
do, to know just get rid of all kinds of
things. There was a great article in the
New Yorker 30 years ago when Bobby
Fischer was playing Spassky in in in in
that famous chess match which drew
attention around the world and they
examined
how the mind
could with
billions and billions and billions of
possibilities how it could group things
so as to immediately cast it down to
where you had like four options.
And of course, when the when the
when the humans play something like Deep
Thought you know, or whatever the latest
version is with the computer on that,
that computer is making maybe 700,000 or
a million calculations a second.
And the human mind is competing against
that, but the computer is checking every
possibility.
And the human mind
somehow
has this ability to cast out 99.999%
of those things that the computer has to
go through in order to focus on the
three or four possibilities that really
make sense. And investing is a lot like
this, not that tough because there
aren't that many companies, but the you
want to cast out all kinds of things. If
somebody told me
that my life depended
on
picking among the Dow Jones stocks
a group of 10 that would be the best
performers or or or or outperform the
index as a whole
I would spend my time thinking of the
worst up companies in there. I would
cast out things and then I would figure
I'd left those behind and I would I
would that's an easier way to approach
the problem actually than than than
trying to pick the 10 best.
So,
you would have to
if you were thinking about the state of
Tennessee, you know, there's a whole lot
of things you wouldn't examine.
You just figure they're too tough.
You might decide, you know, car
dealerships were too tough. It's always
going to be competitive. Who knows
whether Ford or General Motors are going
to be selling more cars 5 years from now
or whether there's going to be tariffs
on foreign cars or who knows. So, you
just have I'll give up on car dealers.
I'll give up on I'll think about
something else. And
uh that approach
uh
that you use there is the same approach
you really want to bring to the stock
market. You've got 3,000 companies
tonight you can look at on the New York
Stock Exchange. There's a valuation on
every one of them. It'll change
tomorrow.
You don't have to play.
Once a year, if you have 20 good I If
you have five good ideas in your
lifetime you get very rich.
You know, I I I tell students sometime
they'd be better off if they had a punch
card when they got out of school with
only 20 punches on it because then
instead of listening to somebody at a
cocktail party and then going out the
next morning buying some shares, they'd
really think about every punch. And
that's all the punches you get. 20
punches is plenty, you know.
You just have to make sure that you
don't do any of them for frivolous
reasons.
We never want to buy anything smaller at
Berkshire.
It just doesn't make any difference, you
know, we want to think about things that
can move the needle.
And that gets tougher as the capital
gets greater. But that's the way to
focus on investments.
Who's next? Mr. Buffett,
how do you determine when to sell a
stock? What factors do you consider?
Yeah, well,
question is about selling and
when I
started investments
when I entered Ben's class, I had about
$9,800
and
the whole problem then was I had way
more ideas than money. I mean, I was
looking for things, I was going through
all the Moody's manuals and digging up
ideas and stocks with all kinds of
things that were cheap, but I still only
had $9,800. So, I would buy something
and then I would find something that
looked even cheaper
uh or better and I would have to sell
the first thing to buy the second thing.
That was my
my state for a long time.
Now,
in the late 1960s, I wound up my
partnership because I couldn't find
things, but that's because the whole
market had gone crazy. And at that time
I was working with about $100 in the
partnership when I wound up the
partnership. Uh
but $100 wasn't an unmanageable amount
of money.
It's just that the market itself was
just offering nothing at the uh and so I
sent the money back to my partners.
But
as the years have gone by and
the capital I've working with has
increased
you know, there's fewer and fewer
opportunities. So, I
virtually Well, I never have to sell
anything now to raise money to buy
something else. I mean, it it just
doesn't happen that way. I've got more
Now, I've got more money than ideas.
Uh and it'll probably stay that way. Uh
so,
I would say that
when you're in a position with
relatively little capital, you sell
something when you find something that
offers you more for your money. And And
or about which you're sure. I mean, if
two things are equally look equally
cheap
but you feel one is you're you're 100%
certain you really understand the
business and the other you got 80%
certainty, you go with the one you're
certain of.
Uh if you're in
my position, you basically don't sell.
Uh or very seldom. Now, looking back, we
should have sold some things when the
bubble was on because the valuations got
so high that even if we'd sold
and they were good businesses, but they
just were ridiculous prices. And and uh
so, with hindsight, that would have been
the thing to do, but I don't feel
terrible about that because the money
would have gone into cash and we might
have bought them back cheaper, but we
might not have. And and generally
speaking
if
if you've got a lot of capital
you know, you're not going to find that
many wonderful ideas. And you know, if
you look at the fortunes that are made
in this country, generally they've been
by owning a good business for a long
period of time. I mean, that's not the
worst thing in the world. And
that's the way people who joined with me
in
in the '50s and '60s, they just
they held on a a number of them.
And
they might have danced around and
Berkshire was too high at certain times,
they might have tried to sell it and buy
it back, but usually that doesn't work
very well. So, I would say that
if you lose confidence in the management
or the business, you sell. I mean, you
there's no sense owning something where
the competitive advantage is gone or
where you think the management is bad
news.
You may wish to sell
if price if the price gets too high.
Uh but that's more optional. The first
two you should do. Second the third is
is is somewhat optional. But if you're
working with small sums of money and
uh I mean, I was finding things in the
initially that were selling at like two
times earnings, good businesses.
And so, if I found something at a two
times earnings and I owned something at
three times earnings, I
I sold the three times to buy the two
times. Looking back, I should have
borrowed a little money and kept both,
but I that wasn't my style.
Mr. Buffett, when trying to value a
company, do you place greater emphasis
on the P/E ratio or the PEG, price
earnings growth? Or is there another
metric you use to value a company? The
most important thing
to learn is how to value a business.
It's also the toughest to explain.
Uh
you know, I look for certain
you you look for certain things that
allows you to narrow it down like I was
saying about, you know, the
Spassky-Fischer situation. So, if I'm a
basketball coach,
you know, and I see a guy and I'm
walking down the street around the
campus here and I see somebody 7-ft
tall, I'm interested. You know,
now,
he may not be coordinated.
He may not be able We may not be able to
keep him in school.
You know, he may be robbing, you know,
stores at night or something, but he's
still the right guy to be looking at,
you know. I mean, we can work with this
guy.
So, I am interested in 7-footers, maybe
6'10.
And if I see some guy who's 5'3 and he
comes up to me and he's dribbling away
and he's telling me, you know, doing
fancy moves and he says, "Coach,
you know, I said, "I'm your guy."
I say, "Yeah,
but you know,
you get in there against these
7-footers,
I'm not sure he'll be dribbling exactly
the same way. I I just I'm going to skip
him. You know, he may be a wonderful
prospect and all that, but I'm not
interested. So, I am looking for things,
signals,
that tell me in investments
what height and a few things might tell
me if I was a basketball coach.
In the end,
what I'm going to buy
is the business where I feel extremely
certain about the competitive advantage,
extremely certain about the integrity
and ability of the management,
and where I think
the discounted flow of the cash that
business will produce over time
makes sense in relation to its current
price.
Uh
you really are looking for a business
where you see the future.
And that's why we you know, we don't get
in tech. It isn't that I don't love the
computer and think it's doing all kinds
of things for society. I just don't know
what it's going to look like
in terms of who's going to be selling
what to whom and at what prices and
against whom and all of that sort of
thing 10 years from now. Whereas I know
the people are going to be chewing
Wrigley's chewing gum in 10 years.
I mean, people sitting in front of a
computer
chewing gum will not behave way
differently than people chewing gum, you
know, in this audience as we talk. I
mean, it's it's it there are certain
things that won't be affected.
Uh Gillette razor blades. I mean, you
know, that uh
70% of the value worldwide
of razors and blades is Gillette. That's
after almost 100 years
of shaving and everybody knows what a
razor blade does. They all know how to
buy the steel. They all know how to sell
it through Walmart or whomever.
But 70% of the world. Now, part of
that's cuz men don't like to change as
much. I mean, men gets happy with
something, he doesn't fool around with
it a lot. Women are a little more
inclined to experiment, but
but
you know, for $25 a year, something you
do every day, you get a wonderful
experience with Gillette.
You know,
what better is the world going to offer
him?
You know, you're getting a claim
currently about some four-blade razor,
but don't worry about that one. The uh
70% Just think of that.
You know, Coca-Cola,
19 billion cases
of of Coke. I mean,
uh not Coke, but Coke products sold a
year at uh
you know, everybody in the world
drinking it. Do you think
will that change dramatically in the
next 10 years? I
you know, I bet my life against that.
But uh
we sell we sell See's Candy in
California.
Uh 35 million people in California.
Uh they did the right thing last
Tuesday, incidentally. The uh
the
People ask how I got involved in the
Schwarzenegger
campaign. I want a look-alike contest. I
mean, it's a the
the uh
But here they are, 35 million people.
Everybody in California has something in
their mind about See's Candy, you know.
What candies are in your mind?
You know, number one
candy bar Snickers. Number one candy bar
10 years ago was Snickers. Number one
candy bar 20 years ago was Snickers.
People don't fool around
with candy bars. I mean, you cannot come
out with lots of new bars
and intrigue people. It's not like, you
know,
perfume or other things maybe that where
people experiment. If you go into the
drugstore and you say, "I want a
Snickers bar."
and it's 60 cents
and the druggist says, "I've got
something just as good for 55 cents
called
Joe Schmo's, you know,
caramel and nut bar."
You're going to walk across the street.
Now, when you walk across the street for
a product,
then you got a business. I mean, that is
the test and where a nickel doesn't make
a difference. And so, it's you know,
there is no good way to compete with
Snickers.
You want something where price
competition is not solely going to be
the determining factor. And that's true
of razor blades, it's true of Snickers,
it's true of See's Candy, it's true of
Coca-Cola.
And there's a lot of things of which it
isn't true. That mode is what is
differentiation of product,
differentiation of service,
differentiation of location, whatever it
may be.
And and and and that's that's essential.
Next.
Hi. Clayton Lewis.
Mr. Buffett, have the extensive
technological changes in market
mechanisms and the internet over the
last 20 years caused a meaningful shift
in investor psychology
or
not participate in them.
The proper temperament
is far more important in successful
investing
than points of intellect. You know, I
mean, if you've got a reasonable
intellect
and the right temperament, you'll get
very rich.
And if you've got the the wrong
temperament for
you know, you'll get done in at some
point.
Anything times zero is zero. I mean, you
know, it's uh
uh they found that out at Long-Term
Capital Management, for example, in
1998. What happened,
you know, what happened very, very, very
seldom,
but it does happen.
You know, you had uh
you know,
where was the largest earthquake in the
United States, Continental United
States,
uh
in our recorded history?
It was in New Madrid, Missouri, you
know. Now, nobody down at New Madrid is
sitting there worrying about another 8.4
or something, but it was, you know, it
was an extraordinary event. In fact,
there were three of them in about
2-month period. Uh
Things the improbable happens.
And in financial markets,
the improbable happens far more often
than people think by running statistical
regressions and so on. It's uh
five sigma events aren't five sigma
events. And uh
it
you just You just have to keep your
sanity, basically.
If you just always write down on a piece
of paper, if you're buying stock in a
company,
whether it makes widgets or it's an
internet company and has 100 million
shares out and selling at 10,
you say, "I am buying XYZ at a billion
dollars." You're buying the business
because
and then just list down the reasons.
And
if more people did that, you know, you
wouldn't have had you won't have
bubbles, but they won't do it. So,
they'll do they'll in exactly to the
same emotions that people have for
centuries and centuries and centuries.
And
like I say, that's that's what makes
incredible opportunities in the stock
market.
I mean, that's why stocks
frequently have a high that's twice the
low in a given year when everybody knows
the business doesn't change in value
like that except under an unusual
circumstances.
Yep.
Um Mr. Buffett, I'm very interested in
knowing what exactly the world's
greatest investor does with his time. Um
specifically, could you walk us through
a typical day in the life of Warren
Buffett? And uh without revealing your
bag of tricks, what sort of activities
you might undertake to arrive in your
investing ideas?
Yeah, it's going to be disappointing.
I spend
I now spend at least 12 hours a week on
the internet playing bridge.
Uh
Now,
this is part of my how to get rich
course. They
play bridge. And uh
during the day
I read a lot of things.
Uh I talk to a few people on the phone.
There are no meetings of any kind.
We we have uh
we don't have any meetings. And I mean
in in in we've had
one time I think I got the CEOs together
15 years ago and
talk about something.
But
some of them have never been to Omaha.
They've missed a lot but then what do
they know?
Uh
They uh
it would it would amaze you how
little I do.
And I don't want any lip now that you're
one share shareholders of B.
Uh
uh the uh
I read a lot of annual reports.
Uh
I don't read as many as I used to.
I read a lot of 10-Ks, call up
a few of them every you know, every day.
Uh
I want to understand as many businesses
as I can but I
The nice thing about investing is that
it's cumulative. I mean, it everything I
learned 30 or 40 years ago
you know, it's
it's stored up in my mind.
You're learning all the time. That
doesn't mean you learn about 100% of the
companies or 90% but what I learned
about the oil business, what I learned
about the real estate business, what I
learned about the department store
business you know, it's still there. And
you keep accumulating a little more
knowledge and then every now and then
you see something.
You see one of those seven-footers
walking by and then you try to learn as
much as you can about that specific
operation.
And then you have to act. Sometimes
I I don't call the managers very often.
They usually call me.
I've got managers that call once a year.
I've got one manager that I talk to
virtually every night.
Uh I've got got a few managers I talk to
once a week. It's much much more their
personality. They run their businesses.
They know their businesses. I don't go
into that those businesses to run them
myself. We don't have anybody in
headquarters to run them. So, I'm
counting on people who have built
successful businesses over decades just
to keep doing it. Which isn't a very big
assumption.
And and and they do it. And some of them
like to talk to me.
Some of them apparently don't like to
talk to me. I'm not hurt.
And
you know, I don't I'm not there late at
night. I I'm I'm thinking about things
all the time but at the
you know, I'm normally in there at
8:30 or thereabouts and going about 5.
And uh
probably if you put a stopwatch to me,
I'd probably average
an hour of that time to an hour and a
half on the phone.
And the rest of the time I'd be reading.
One of the beauties about Berkshire from
my standpoint
is I got to create my own business.
I mean, I it was a pretty much a blank
slate when I got there. I had the
textile business but I got to paint a
painting.
Now, if you're going to get to paint
your own a painting, you really ought to
paint something you're going to like
when you get through.
And I don't like meetings, you know. I
don't like I don't like lots of
you know, I don't like lots of process
or that sort of thing.
So, I have painted Berkshire
as a corporate painting that suits me.
And it and it and it it works well for
me. It might not work for somebody else.
I wouldn't be worth a darn in some
organization where I had to
go to a black tie event five times a
week, you know, and go to
go to industry conferences and
everything. I just wouldn't do it. I'd
go back to delivering papers cuz it's
more fun. And that's really the way I
feel.
So, Berkshire is designed
so that I can play a lot of bridge and
read a lot of stuff.
And I you know, I I can't imagine
enjoying life more because if there was
something else I'd enjoyed more, I'd be
doing it. But that's that's that's a day
at Berkshire.
Sounds exciting, doesn't it?
Yeah.
Hi.
Mr. Buffett, over a 40-year period, what
would you expect the average normal US
stock market return to be?
40 years, huh?
Well, I'll be around to give you that
answer. Uh
the uh
Well, I would say
that if you're in a period
of those 40 years where inflation
averages two or
to 3%
you're
in what I would call sort of normal you
don't you don't have any huge
aberrations in the world on a macro
scale then
I would say that
the average business
will produce
over that period something like 7%
but investors
that's what if nobody did anything. If
we just all here sat and bought
corporate America together.
We bought every share and we never
traded with each other.
Our group I think would average
something like 7% in that
uh
environment where nothing really
dramatically
changed.
Now because
American investors have been taught to
think they have to move around all the
time.
And you have to sell to the person next
to you and they have to sell to somebody
else.
Investors incur what I call frictional
costs.
You incur them when you buy a mutual
fund, there's a management fee, perhaps
in a load and a 12b-1 fee. You incur you
incur them when you buy stocks
individually. There's all kinds of
frictional costs in the system.
Those frictional costs
probably for investors as a whole
come to something like 1%
annually.
Uh you can keep them down yourself. The
frictional costs of somebody who owns
his own Berkshire for 40 years has been
virtually zero. So, they paid the tiny
commission one time and and and
management fees are low. So,
it doesn't have to be that way.
But because stocks
are looked at so much like being in a
casino for so many people
the American public as a whole will
incur these 1% frictional costs. So,
that 7% if that happens to be the figure
correctly will turn into 6% for the
American public as a whole and 1% will
dribble away
to investment managers and brokers and
people who sell the
advice and all all kinds of frictional
costs.
When you think about it, that's a pretty
hefty take.
It's one out of seven. It'd be 14% of
the returns from business.
But
that's that's my best guess
as to what will happen. You can keep
your own frictional costs down and let
somebody else
pay a lot more of the frictional costs.
But if if you're in an investment if
you're playing in an investment arena
and you are incurring frictional costs
of two or 3% think of what the day
traders were incurring, you know.
But
you were you were giving away an awful
lot of
of the underlying
business results that America will
achieve.
Cuz General Motors
or Exxon
and American Telephone how much they
earn has got nothing to do
with how much all their shareholders
incur if they keep changing chairs all
the time. Every time you change shares
with somebody in this room, we own the
whole place. You both pay something.
If you just sit tight, the companies
will make the money but uh that they
make and that will all belong to you.
But if you move around a lot, it will it
will belong to the people who either
advise you to move around or shepherd
you from one chair to another.
Yep. Mr. Buffett, what is your future
outlook on the US financial market and
the health of global economy, especially
China? Hm.
Future Western civilization.
Well
over a long period of time, markets will
behave
pretty much like they've always behaved.
Most of the time they will be valuing
businesses
in a reasonable range and they will go
crazy periodically on the upside and
downside. In 1974, they went totally
crazy on the downside. I mean, you can't
believe how cheap major businesses
got in the period like '74.
Uh
businesses
were doing fine. The Washington Post
Company
sold in the market the whole company
for $80 million. It owned the Washington
Post newspaper. It owned Newsweek. It
owned four great big network television
stations including one in Washington
and one in Miami, one in Jacksonville,
one in Hartford.
It had half interest in Bowater Mersey
Paper, 800,000 acres of timberland it
had
third interest in the International
Herald Tribune. Didn't owe any money to
speak of.
$80 million. It's a
It's a joke.
Uh at that time
you could have announced
that you were going to hold an auction
of their properties
in the middle of the Atlantic Ocean at
2:00 in the morning
you know.
And you would have had people show up
who would have paid at least $500
million for those same properties. Now,
imagine buying $500 million worth of
properties, good businesses
for $80 million.
You know, in this world, all these
people with high IQs around studying at
finance at major business schools, all
kinds of things.
1/5 or 1/6
what the business is worth. The Graham
family was obviously both honest and
talented.
They were in good businesses.
Well, that company today
would know they haven't discovered oil.
They've got the pretty much the same
businesses.
You know, it is it's now selling
for 7 billion or thereabouts. And but
there's nothing magic about it. They
haven't discovered anything. You know,
it it was a it was a $500 million
business that became a $7 billion
business over a 30-year period with good
management, decent properties and all of
that. And you could have bought it for
80 million.
You know, we we own at Berkshire
some Washington Post stock that we paid
$10 million, less than $10 million for
and which is now worth a billion, too.
Or something of the sort.
And
it was nothing esoteric about it at all.
It's just people go crazy.
And
if you ask me about the financial
markets in the future,
I will absolutely confidently predict. I
just don't know when and I don't know
what order. I don't know whether people
will get greedy before they get fearful
or vice versa.
But over the next 30 or 40 years,
you'll see some incredible
aberrations. And you have to be able to
think independently
at that time.
The US market
is 13 or 14 trillion of equities.
You know, it's
probably close
I haven't looked at the figures lately,
but it's close to half the world's
market. So,
you don't really need an actually
got even more money than I
once you're at Berkshire that just gave
gave you uh
it you'd
you don't really need the rest of the
world to look at. I mean, when you own
Coca-Cola, you're having
well over 2/3 of your earnings coming
from outside the United States. Same way
with Gillette and all of that. So,
uh if you want to expand your universe,
there's nothing wrong with it, but you
can the United States will do well over
the next 30 or 40 years. Mr. Buffett,
can you give us your general opinion on
real estate investment?
Well, real estate
in most of you're talking about actual
direct ownership of real estate,
you know, you're talking local markets
basically. Now,
many people have an advantage in that
because they do know their own locale
the best. But
uh
there's nothing magic about any asset
category.
Uh
or anything terrible about me. I
You know, what do I think about stocks?
It depends what stocks, when, what
price, all kinds of things. It's the
same way with real estate, but I would
say that
for many people,
you know, it is something very
understandable for them.
And it's something actually where in
some cases if you're on a small scale,
you sweat equity
can do things for you, too.
Uh people generally own real estate and
have it leveraged somewhat so that
you get a magnified return plus or minus
because you leverage that. And I don't
advise leveraging stocks. It's easier to
leverage real estate.
It's less dangerous. I mean, people look
at the
property and you can get long-term
loans. Whereas I I regard leveraging in
in uh stocks as being absolute rat
poison. Uh
it it's probably broken more smart
people than anything else that than
mistakes in judgment. And
uh I've never used any leverage to
to speak of, but in real estate, it
would be perfectly appropriate
in in in a in a lot of cases. I think
the average
I think many people
would know far more about the real
estate they own
if they got involved in direct in their
locale on on on on
on local uh
area than than
people often know about the stocks they
own or about the investment advisor
they're using.
Uh so, I I
I've done a little in that over the
years, not a lot, but I think it's a
perfectly fine category. But it gets
down to predicting the income stream
from the asset and comparing it to the
present price. I mean, that's that's
true if you buy oil royalties. It's true
of any kind of investment. Investment
means laying out money now to get more
money later on. And how sure are you of
getting that money later on? And if you
feel more certain because you know more
about the game
in real estate than in stocks, then I
advise you to stick to your circle of
competence is in real estate more than
stocks. I mean, you you ought to go into
the game you know the best.
Mr. Buffett, do you feel that domestic
man- manufacturing concerns such as the
auto industry will ever be able to
successfully compete with foreign
producers again? That's a terrific
question. Uh
uh and I may be writing a little
something on that
very soon. But the uh
you know, we have lost
our ability to compete in in some very
major industries. I was in textiles.
You know, it was a tough tough business
and it it's gotten tougher since I got
out of it. And and the truth is we are
not very competitive
with a world, you know, the our our
Fruit of the Loom underwear
uh
maybe
I'm pulling the number out, but it's
close. 16,000 out of 20,000 of our
employers are working outside the United
States. And that production has even
moved out of Mexico where some of it was
to lower cost countries.
We're in the shoe business.
Americans wear 1.2 or buy buy, they
don't wear. They buy 1.2 billion pairs
of shoes a year.
Four per capita. I I To me, that boggles
my mind. I I buy a pair of shoes about
every 10 years. But we're a nation of
Imelda Marcoses. I mean, we're buying
shoes like crazy, but we're not making
any here anymore. You know, we used to
make most of that
of the domestic of the domestic sales.
And now I would say of that billion two,
I'd be surprised if more than 50 million
pair
are made in the United States. That's
that's hundreds of thousands of jobs.
You're now seeing it in furniture
manufacturing. Our furniture retailers
are going over
to China primarily, but other parts of
the Orient. We're buying because we buy
in big quantities, we can send our
people over. We buy that furniture over
there. And and and and frankly, you
know, in in great many cases, you can't
tell the difference except the
difference is in price. So,
American consumer
is going to vote for good quality, low
price merchandise.
And
the auto industry, you know, we are
still quite strong in autos.
The biggest problem our domestic auto
companies have is legacy costs.
Back in the 1960s,
General Motors was was
virtually the number one company in the
country. Probably was the number one
company in the country. People thought
of General Motors being. They had over
50% of the car production. They really
just worried about having too much.
And
they made some contracts back then
uh
where they made promises for the future
uh particularly in post-retirement
health as well as pensions
that and in health well and pensions at
that time, too, they didn't have to put
the cost
through the income account. I mean, it
shows you how
bad accounting can lead to bad decisions
because they could make these promises
to people. If they were an insurance
company and they made those same
promises, they would have had to record
the liability. But as an auto company
making those promises, they didn't have
to make they didn't have to record the
liability. Choice when the UAW came
around from bargaining tough on wages
versus bargaining
on giving people something on
post-retirement health and and and and
and pensions.
And they gave away the cost they gave a
lot in terms of the cost that wasn't
going to count on their current year's
income account to avoid some other
costs, namely hourly wages, that would
count. So, they made all of these
decisions which started coming home to
roost. They came home to roost in terms
of the actual payments to be made. Plus,
they changed the accounting rules, so
they didn't even get away with it
eventually in terms of accounting. They
they went to pensions first and started
recording and then they went to
post-retirement health.
So, now you have a company
uh like General Motors where the current
management
is essentially saddled with running an
insurance company, a huge insurance
company
with huge health payments, huge pension
payments. They've got more people
collecting those payments that are
actually working for them.
And that becomes
you know, that has to go into the cost
of a car. And it makes them less
competitive with the rest of the world
than what otherwise be the case. We try
to avoid if we can businesses with a
very high
uh labor content where that labor could
be duplicated elsewhere because you
know, after 45 years, whatever it may
be, I I finally learned something that
that if somebody else is
is paying a worker a quarter or a fifth
of what we're paying, they're going to
kill me, you know, if it's the same
product.
Mr. Buffett.
Mr. Buffett, a decade ago, or not a
decade, but a generation ago, people
would have careers that went from, you
know, maybe one or two career changes
over the span of their lifetime and then
they would retire. My peers and I are
looking at almost eight different career
changes, much less job changes, over the
course of our career lifetime. How do
you think that's affected the workforce
in America? Has it had a good impact or
a bad impact?
Well, I I can just tell you in terms of
our own business. I I wouldn't want to
take any job. I mean, I had jobs in
summer during the school and all of
that. But
but I I wouldn't want to take a job
unless I
would be happy having that job and
presumably promotions along the way, but
the rest of my life. I mean, I think it
is crazy
to
do a whole bunch of things you don't
like
with the idea that you're building your
resume or that you're going to six job
changes later, you're going to finally
be in the place
where you want to be. I mean, that
I had a fellow once in school that
as he was taking me to school, he said,
you know, I
went to undergraduate here and then I
had a job at this auditing firm and I'm
at graduate school and then I'm going to
go He said, now he he said, maybe it was
about
you know, 30 31. He said, I'm now going
to do the
thinking of
going with a management consulting firm
because I think that would sort of round
out my resume.
And he said, what do you think?
I said, well, it
What I think is it sounds like saving up
sex for your old age. You know, I mean,
you know, when are you going to actually
do something you enjoy? You know,
it's crazy."
So, the first thing to do is get a job,
you know, with somebody that you admire
or some company you admire, something
you enjoy doing. You may be there there
the rest of your life, you may not, but
you ought to look at it as as if you're
going to be there the rest of your life.
And
and I, you know, we have people
Berkshire, basically, who've devoted
their lives to their businesses. Al
Yoshi runs Flight Safety. Al started
1951 with $10,000. I mean, it's a the
leading flight training school in the
world. Uh
Uh and our school, a lot of campuses, a
lot of simulators. And
you know, he is doing at 85 or so what
he loves doing. And be crazy, you know,
you presumably only live once. I mean,
Shirley MacLaine may know better, but
but they uh
you know, you you
you don't get a you don't get the years
back. So, you you ought to be doing what
you enjoy. And I I think anybody that
job hops a lot is is missing something
in life. And if people are doing it
more, I think
it's probably a mistake. Uh that doesn't
mean you can't change. You're going to
get new opportunities or maybe you find
out that you know, that isn't the
business you want to be in, but
you ought to go in with the intention
that you ought to go into a job that
where you feel like hopping out of bed
in the morning, you know, and you can't
can't wait to get down to the office.
That's why I feel still at 73. And you
know, I'll I'll feel that way because
it's it's exciting every day. And and on
the other hand,
all kinds of jobs
that even if I had no money, I wouldn't
take for any price, you know. I really
would rather deliver papers or something
like that uh than have a whole bunch of
jobs that maybe do things during the day
or the evening
that I didn't want to do it.
It would be crazy
if I could make
pick a figure, if I could make $75,000 a
year and have my 12 hours
for bridge a week and I had to give
those up in order to make $300,000 a
year, I wouldn't do it, you know.
Mr. Buffett, what are the most important
qualities you look for in a management
team when considering purchasing a
company? The most important qualities
what?
Qualities of a management team when
considering purchasing a company.
Well, you want in a management team, you
I mean, you do want people that love
their businesses. I mean, the first
thing I look at in buying a business
because usually the people
that are
selling to me are going to be running it
subsequently. Not every time, but most
of the time.
You know, I have to look at them and
decide, do they love the money or do
they love the business? I would never
rely on a contract
to keep somebody around. Uh so, I'm
looking for somebody
that's in love with their business. Al
Yoshi's in love with his business.
I mean, he does it because he'd rather
he he likes training
people and he feels he's saving lives,
and it's true. I mean,
pilot training in this country has
improved enormously over the last 50
years. It's safer because pilots are
better trained. And he feels good about
that.
And he feels just as good now as he did
50 years ago about it. He loves the
business. He got paid a lot of money for
it, but he's
but he's not working for money.
So, I'm looking for a management that is
doing something they love. And
obviously, I'm looking for,
you know, honest people, but that
usually comes with it. You know, I say
in in in essence, what we're looking for
in managers or employees generally,
we're looking for people with
intelligence,
energy,
and integrity.
And if they don't have the last one, the
first two will kill you.
Cuz if you have somebody without
integrity, you don't want them to be
smart and energetic. You want them to be
dumb and lazy, you
They they won't do much for you if
they're dumb and lazy. But if they but
if you get those three qualities, and we
get them, I mean, we find people like
that. You know, if somebody's run a
business successfully for 30 years,
you know, they are
they're plenty smart at the business.
They're energetic, they wouldn't have
gotten there otherwise. And the truth is
they wouldn't want to harm that business
whether they own it or not. I mean, it's
it's like one of their children in many
cases. And they they, you know, they
they love it. It's their painting, they
created it. So, it'd be like slashing
the painting, you know, if they if they
did anything to it subsequently. And we
we've been very lucky
in finding those people. I mean, we
they've
uh Berkshire is a good home for them.
And
that fact has been established. And so
so, we get this natural filter through
which people come to Berkshire. Uh they
see that this if they for one reason or
another they need to do something with
their business that Berkshire is a very
good home for it. And it is. It But that
means we also get some
terrific residents of that home.
Mr. Buffett, what are three areas or
industries
where you might initially
locate that one in a thousand companies
in which you might concentrate heavily?
Well, I would look at things I
understood, of course. And you know, I
understand insurance. I've been in the
business a long time.
Uh I I understand most financial
businesses.
Uh I understand certain aspects of
retailing. Re- retailing can be tricky,
but I certainly understand that. So, I
would just look at the things I
understood the most.
Now,
we do things by accident because they
come along. I mean, it uh uh
You know,
I didn't I didn't set out to be you
know, be in the underwear business a
couple years ago. I mean, probably all
of you have dreamt all your life of
being in the underwear business, but uh
I hadn't thought a lot about it, but
Fruit of the Loom was in bankruptcy.
And
I was very familiar, actually, with that
company in other ways than you might
guess. And
the uh
in fact, I I really had become
first familiar with over 45 years
earlier.
And I understood what was going on in
the It's not a complicated business. You
go into Walmart and basically, you see,
you know, Fruit of the Loom and Hanes.
And uh uh
it had had a terrible financial history
because they borrowed too much money
against it and them it it had it gotten
badly managed for a period, but that was
solvable.
So,
I had a mind that was prepared
in effect with a background
that enabled me to understand what was
being offered.
Then we have a fabulous manager who had
earlier run it when it did well, who was
willing to come back, John Holland. And
I knew with the combination of John
Holland, the strength of the brand, the
nature of that kind of business,
that it was something we would go into.
But it I didn't have a checklist ahead
of time.
It just it came up on the screen, in
effect.
It came up because somebody borrowed too
much money on it. It came up because of
a bankruptcy. If they hadn't followed
earlier erroneous policies, I never
would have
I never would have seen it. If I
couldn't have gotten John Holland to
come back and run it, I wouldn't have
bought it.
Cuz I mean, it
you know, what do I know about making
underwear? So, the
the
uh
the key is understanding the industries.
And you probably can understand some
that I can't and vice versa. I've been
in retailing a lot now. We own
group of furniture businesses, and I
think I could probably evaluate
another furniture retailer pretty easily
after the experiences I have. Plus, I've
got
a group of five great managers,
actually, that could tell me a lot about
the management of any
new one that came along and tell me
about the trade position. And I'm But I
could learn a lot of it myself, too.
So, I'm
I I don't have three industries in my
mind that I'm thinking about now that I
want to look at tomorrow.
We're buying a company in bankruptcy
that that uh
uh essentially sells seismic data
as a library
of seismic data.
And they got in trouble because they
borrowed too much money and went into a
lot of crazy ventures, too.
But it's a very sound business. It's not
a huge business, but I can understand
what the possessor of a library of
seismic data can can do in terms of
selling that information or renting it
to uh
uh to people that are interested in in
in drilling in given areas.
Uh that wasn't on my radar screen at all
until in May or June the chance to buy
actually the whole bond issue and
thereby and the probably having the
company came along. So, you just have to
be prepared, and then you have to know
what you can know and what you can't
know. I mean, you have to really know
where that circle of competence is.
That's that's very important. Yep.
Hi.
Katie Gaston. Good to see you.
Uh Mr. Buffett, in petroleum energy
investment, which do you prefer? Oil
refinement refinement, um oil services,
or oil exploration?
Well, oil refi- I've been in
When I was at Salomon, we had a
hundreds of thousands of barrels a day
of
of refining capacity and uh
uh it's an interesting Refining's kind
of interesting because it always looked
like it was going to get tight. It's a
it's a commodity business. You don't
know what refinery the cash you put in
your tank comes from. You don't care.
You know, I mean, gas is gas to you. So,
the only time the refining business is
going to be good
is when it's tight.
Now, one thing that helps to make it
tight is people don't build new
refineries in this country, very you
know, it it is a tough business. Got a
lot of environmental problems and all of
that. So, you would think with oil
demand going up over the years
and no more refineries being built,
that it would get tight at some point.
I waited a long time for that point.
They they have something in that
business called capacity creep, which
means that you figure out ways to tweak
the 200,000 barrel a day refinery so
that it does 210 next year or something
of the sort. So, you have these kind of
fuzzy capacity things. So, the only time
you want to be in the refining business,
and I wouldn't want to be in it at all
because I wouldn't be trying to time
some
bump. But is is one that one that's
going to be tight.
Uh
the production business
uh
has not been a great business in this
country. I mean it it you know, you're
buying a product
you're buying it by drilling in the
ground basically and incurring various
costs. And basically you sell that
product depending on the life of the
field over maybe an average of 10 years.
Well,
something that you lay out money for now
to get paid money over 10 years,
you know, has to bring a big multiple
of the price you lay out now. I mean,
you're you're it's got a long inventory
cycle in effect. I mean, you sell your
inventory over a long period. And it's
not been a terrible business. If you
look at the aggregate record, in fact,
this is more offshore than I mean, not
in the United States, but if you look at
Exxon and Royal Dutch and BP and those,
they've had a pretty good record in
terms of return on capital over time.
Um
but I would
I mean, Howard Hughes made his money
because
you know, he had a very proprietary or
his dad had it originally, a very
proprietary
uh product at Hughes Tool.
And if you've got something where
somebody is spending $100,000, pick a
figure,
on drilling a well and you've got a
$400 product that's terribly important
to the success of the $100,000 product,
that's a great position to be in. I
mean, you want to look for that all the
time where what you've got is a
relatively small piece of the
some very big project that's the whole,
but you've got a key piece. And you will
not get
you know, that will not be a narrow
margin business if you've if you're the
only one that's got it. So, it would in
oil services it would depend on
the specific
type of product I had and then and how
long I thought
either the patent on it would last or
that one way or another I could protect
that proprietary position. Uh
uh
Oil is something we look at. You know,
it's a matter of record we own
um
we're the third largest holder of
PetroChina.
PetroChina
uh
is
it produces about 80% as much oil
as Exxon.
And um nobody's most a lot of people
never heard of it, but it it's
producing, you know, 2 million
barrels a day, which is, you know, close
to 3% of the world's output or
thereabouts
of oil and it's got a lot of oil. It's a
very big company. It was selling at a
very low price
uh
a year ago.
Uh
Now, on top of that, oil's going up and
actually China ties their price of oil
within their borders to the world
uh price, so
it it its profitability fluctuates with
oil prices, but it's a big integrated
oil company that that uh
is of a size that's not dramatically
below
uh
you know, the Exxons or
of the world. And
you know, it was selling at a very low
multiple.
Annual report was perfectly
understandable.
And so, I just read it one day.
It's in English, fortunately.
Wouldn't have been very good otherwise,
but you know, it it it made made as much
sense as American annual reports make.
And it was in a multiple of
earnings that was a
uh
huge discount from where other
major oil company sold. And it looked
like they were going to use the money as
intelligently,
you know, as as any other oil company.
So,
that's why we ended up buying something
like that. The Chinese government owns
90% of it, so
it's a little like your B stock in
Berkshire. I mean, if I vote with the
Chinese government, the two of us
control it, but
but that
I I would
People have made money in refining at
certain times. There's a there's a
you know, what they call the crack
spread and you can figure it out in
terms of what
what heating oil and and and and
gasoline and other things you're selling
for compared to crude. And when that
spread gets wide,
uh refiners are going to make a lot of
money, but they don't really have any
control over that except
when business gets tight.
In our textile business, we used to make
money for about 10 minutes every year.
And the time when we made money, we made
we made the linings for men's suits. We
made a half the linings
for men's suits in the country.
And nobody ever went into a a tailor and
said, "I'd like a
you know, I like a pinstripe gray suit
with a halfway lining." So, it was a
terrible business.
And we would get in voted supplier of
the year and all of those things. Then
we try and raise our prices a quarter
percent a yard and they say, "What's
your name?" You know, I mean, they had
no interest in us. So, that was a real
commodity business. The only time we
made any money
was when rayon got tight.
And because we had an allocation from
DuPont,
we got X number of pounds.
In effect, when
if if rayon got tight,
we could raise the price of linings
because other people couldn't get rayon
then. And it it ceased to become a
commodity.
And then like I say, about a day later
it would go back to its old form. But
that was that was the whole thing. It
wasn't really all this work we did
in you know, in in in in in weaving all
these things, all of those spindles and
all of the all of the looms and
everything,
the money we made was just because of
our rayon allocation. And when the rayon
allocation was worth money, we made
money and when it wasn't, we didn't make
any money.
And
that's what happens in commodity
business. They're brutal.
They're wonderful occasionally, but
they're brutal.
Hi. I'm Hong Kong. Nice to Nice to meet
you.
Mr. Buffett, earlier you talked a lot
about your investment philosophies.
Could you sum me that and just give us
one piece of investment advice and what
would it be the most important? Thank
you.
They always want that. Do they?
Now, there
I wish I could, you know, there was one
thing that would do the job, but I would
say those three things that I talked
about earlier. If you if you really get
those down into your
you know, into your spinal cord,
so that
every subsequent decision is processed
through that the stock is a business,
the market's there to to serve you, not
to instruct you, and always have a
margin of safety. If you have that so
that nothing goes through
all your mental filters without all of
those things coming into play,
you won't make any bad investment
decisions, but but there is there's no
magic, you know, I I wish there were,
but but there can't be, you know, as a
practical matter. I mean, I don't
believe in fully efficient markets, but
they're they're reasonably efficient
most of the time. I mean, you've got a
whole lot of smart people trying to make
money. And they try very hard, and
therefore it's a competitive game.
And
there can't be any simple
little thing except work at it. Now, I
will say this, when I got out of school,
uh
there were a lot of things around that
were extraordinarily cheap.
Nobody told me about any of them. I
mean, I literally
had to go through Moody's
Banks and Finance Manual, Industrial
Manual, Transportation Manual, Public
Utility Manual. I
Those would probably total 15,000 pages.
I turned every page, you know, because
nobody was going to tell me some way to
get
to find extremely cheap stocks. And I
found them by going to it. And if I had
small amounts of money now, I would do
the same thing with small companies all
over again. I mean, that you will find
something if you if you work hard enough
at it.
Hi.
Recently Fortune magazine
ranked you as the most powerful man in
business.
I was wondering,
how do you measure success and do you
even take these
these rankings into consideration?
Well, I'll get I'll give you an answer
you may not expect on the success.
Uh
I mean, by busi- if you talk about
business success, which I do not regard
as the ultimate success, but if you talk
about business success, it's it's
running a business successfully over
a long period of time so that
that you do well, your shareholders do
well, and the people who work with you
do well. But but if you really talk
about success as a human being,
you know, it's it's it's at my age,
you are a success
if
the best test
I've got a friend
who
uh was in a concentration camp
in Germany
1942.
And uh
she
lost a member of the family there.
She lives
in Omaha now.
And she says
and she's in her 70s,
she will say to me
that in looking at people,
the bottom line
is would they hide me?
You know, that is the real test.
If you've got a group of if you have a
lot of people
who metaphorically would hide you
at my age, you're going to feel very
good about life. And you are a success.
And if you've got if you lived a life
where nobody would do it, including your
own children,
you know,
including your neighbors,
including the people you work with,
you know, where
they would turn away,
you're a failure, I mean, in my in my
view. And I've I've seen both kinds, you
know, and you know, it's it's the
ultimate measure,
but you can't buy it. I find that a
little irritating. I mean, I you know, I
mean, it's so much easier. Uh
the only way to be loved is to be
lovable.
You know, isn't that terrible? I mean,
you can't write a check out for a
million dollars like a million dollars
worth of love. You know what I mean? I
I've got a lot of friends,
and some of them you know, some of them
that have died now,
that people everybody loved them.
You know, you behave better around them
than you would other people. You took
lessons from them.
And uh
you know, they all died successes. It's
a simple it's a simple equation,
but people
many people don't learn till it's too
late or they develop habits
that
turn other people off,
would turn themselves off if somebody
else had them.
And they they don't seem to learn. It
you know, my old boss Ben Graham
when he was in his low teens
sat down one day and said to himself,
"What things do I like in other people?
What do I admire in other people?"
And he wrote them down.
And he looked at the list and he said,
you know
"What is there on this list I couldn't
be?"
Isn't the ability to throw a football 60
yards
and the ability to, you know, hit a golf
ball 300 yards.
You know, it's human qualities. That's
Think about who you like and admire. And
if you look at those people and you
write down what you admire about them
you will find that every one of those
qualities you can have yourself. And you
can play the reverse side of that. You
can
you can write down qualities that you
dislike in other people cause you to
really avoid them. You know, you don't
want to be associated with them.
And if you write those down, you know,
if you have those qualities people are
going to feel the same way about you,
you know. Now, it's very tough to choose
when you're 60 or 70. I mean, it's
it's that line the chains of habit are
too light to be felt until they're too
heavy to be broken. So, whatever habits
you're developing now you're going to
have at some later date and but you can
have the habits
of the people you admire and get rid of
the habits of the people
that you feel badly about at your age.
That's why That's why I like to talk to
students. I I don't really talk to other
groups. If I talk to a bunch of
guys my age, you know, they want to be
entertained or they want predictions.
But
students you can be whatever you want to
be, you know, from this age forward. And
the truth is when you get to be 70
what you'll care about is who loves you.
See how this works? I've never had one
of these before, but
We got it? Something like that. Anyway.
What I would like to do
is if
if the students will Casey Stengel
Casey Stengel said one time to the
baseball team What is this? I got this
straight? About it? Okay. Casey Stengel
said one time to the baseball team
you know, "Line up alphabetically by
height."
Major funding for this program was
provided by the Clayton Family
Foundation.
And by Clayton Homes, building
affordable homes for families and
individuals throughout the United
States.
To order a copy of Vintage Buffett,
Warren Buffett Shares His Wealth on VHS
tape, call 1-800-733-8657.